[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir les 60 ans
des accords d'evian qui scellèrent la
fin de la guerre entre la france et
l'algérie nous verrons que plus d'un
demi siècle plus tard les douleurs sont
encore vives et la réconciliation des
mémoires un enjeu politique et sociale
pour les deux rives de la méditerranée
à l'occasion de la semaine de la
francophonie on ira dans la plus grande
ville francophone du monde et non ce
n'est pas paris kinshasa en république
démocratique du congo là bas on parle
qui - et pas le français classique
nous testerons votre par les kinois dans
le reportage nos correspondants
est notre invité de ce soir pour la
langue et ses traductions une
fascination il en a fait un objet
philosophique et il n'ya nous présenter
son dernier ouvrage intitulé de langue à
langue le philosophe sénégalais
souleymane bachir diagne est l'invité du
journal de l'afrique
il y à 60 ans jour pour jour était
signer à evian les accord qui met fin à
huit ans de guerre meurtrière entre la
france et l'algérie qui a fait plus de
cinq cent mille morts des accords entre
le gouvernement français et la branche
politique du fln qui me r plus de dix
jours avant d'aboutir le rappel des
faits de nos confrères de france
télévisions
après 11 jours de pourparlers au bord du
lac léman le texte qui met fin à huit
ans de conflit et signer le soir même le
général de gaulle s'adresse aux français
sans jamais prononcer le mot de guerre
la conclusion du cessez le feu en
algérie
les dispositions adoptées
pour que les populations
ils disposent de leurs des stars un
cessez le feu est signé entre le
gouvernement français et le fln le front
de libération nationale il prend effet
dès le lendemain le texte prévoit aussi
un référendum en métropole puis un
référendum d'autodétermination en
algérie le oui l'emporté largement
ouvrant la voie à l'indépendance
si on électorale en france et en algérie
fut très importante mais dans les faits
le conflit continuera de longs mois des
violences éclatent entre le fln lots as
une organisation armée constituée par
des partisans de l'algérie française
les accords sont aussi l'origine d'un
exil celui des pieds noirs ils sont près
d'un million à partir pour la france les
harkis eux doivent choisir entre
s'engager dans l'armée française ou
retourner à la vie civile cette année
une cérémonie se tiendra demain à
l'elysée pour commémorer le 60e
anniversaire de ces accords historiques
cette guerre d'algérie 60 ans après est
toujours au coeur des mémoires qui
saigne selon l'expression consacrée
l'historien benjamin stora
comment réconcilier les mémoires
peut-être en passant par les nouvelles
générations les jeunes issus de cette
histoire qui tentent de se comprendre
plutôt que de raviver les prix reportage
de florence caillat myriam bendali et
laure wagner
[Musique]
il y à 60 ans des dizaines de milliers
de personnes débarquées d'algérie à
marseille
c'est ici que valentin et linda se
retrouvent pour préparer leur prochaine
réunion
[Applaudissements]
excellent
elle est descendante de combattants fln
lui petit-fils de pieds noirs comme on
appelait les français d'algérie à
l'époque et depuis plusieurs mois ils
travaillent ensemble sur les mémoires
franco algérienne
la photo date de 1956 son et grands
parents qui se marient donc
vraisemblablement pas loin de blida donc
c'est le début de la guerre ils ont jugé
bon de faire paraître dans le journal un
couple s'est marié pour montrer que tout
allait bien finalement en algérie
c'était pas si c'était pas si tragique
que ça mon grand-père indépendantiste
disait que pendant cette guerre il n'y
avait pas eu de héros en fait il y avait
juste des des personnes qui voulaient
sauver leur peau sur leurs familles
pour eux plusieurs champs d'action
possibles l'enseignement les témoignages
les lieux de mémoire et surtout le
projet d'un institut franco algérien le
groupe espère aussi attirer de nouvelles
recrues
on aimerait maintenant élargir le cercle
que d'autres jeunes nous rejoignent donc
on a mis en place des réunions publiques
pour ça il ya tellement de gens qui sont
concernés par cette histoire par ses
mémoires que c'est dommage de passer à
côté de cette réflexion collective
il faut qu'on les prennent et c'est
effectivement modestement de l'entamé
mais après c'est à chacun de s'en saisir
[Musique]
le dialogue pour comprendre et avancer
ensemble plutôt que chacun de son côté
avec son drame personnel
[Musique]
on passe au mali ou le médiateur de la
cedeao s'est à nouveau déplacé ce
vendredi l'ancien président nigérian
goodluck jonathan s'est entretenu avec
l'agente malienne et si on en croit les
tweets officiel de la présidence l'objet
serait une résolution rapide de la crise
malienne
et france mes yeux un monde a pris
connaissance d'une procédure engagée par
les autorités maliennes visant à
suspendre la diffusion de rfi et de
france 24 dans le pays le groupe déplore
cette décision et proteste vivement
contre les accusations infondées mettant
gravement en cause le professionnalisme
de ses antennes france médias monde a
entamé les recours et nous continuerons
malgré tout à couvrir l'actualité au
mali mieux possible
en guinée les femmes des différents
partis politiques du parc du pays
s'organisent pour être au coeur de la
transition ce mercredi elles ont mis en
place une plate forme dénommée la
guinéenne en politique à travers cette
organisation ces femmes veulent
désormais avoir leur mot à dire sur
toutes les questions liées à la question
et la gestion de la transition ou propos
recueillis par malik d'équité
c'est obligatoire que les femmes soient
impliqués dans cette transition nous
voulons que cette transition qui est la
troisième en guinée soit réussi et pour
qu'elle le soit il faut que ses filles
et ses fils s'investissent et se donnent
la même pour donner la direction à cette
transition nous sommes à un tournant
historique de notre pays et il est
important que la voix de femmes
politiques sont entendus et nous
comptons bien sûr émettre des
propositions afin que nous puissions
avoir une transition apaisée dans notre
pays à l'occasion de la semaine
internationale la francophonie on vous
emmène dans la plus grande ville
francophone du monde kinshasa là-bas le
français est la langue officielle mais
vous allez le voir la langue du
quotidien n'est pas un français
classique mais plutôt un mélange d'argot
et d'autres langues c'est ce qu'on
appelle le par les kinois longtemps
déconsidéré
et aujourd'hui une place il se fait une
place dans la création artistique
comporte à signer juliette dubois et
clément bonnerot
si vous avez déjà mis les pieds à
kinshasa vous avez sûrement déjà entendu
certaines de ses expressions des amiraux
et les armes tu es marié et puis tu as
l'autre chalotte copine ailleurs bouffer
l'argent c'est déjà escroqué mairie à
paléo donc comment ce que je suis dur
donc moins que la femme votre palm
légitimes comme la journée c'est juste
pour calmer le ventre ce langage imagé
mélange d'argot et d'autres langues
comme le lingala et le kikongo c'est le
par les kinois le dialecte du quotidien
de la capitale congolaise et ses 15
millions d'habitants longtemps perçue
comme un simple langage de rue il a fait
son entrée dans la littérature avec ce
premier roman écrit il ya quatre ans n'a
soir vers 19 heures n'a débarqué à
l'improviste secteur nabarro les loin à
reconnaître silhouette ya renate bras
dessus bras dessous joël makengo en est
l'auteur pour lui le kinois a toute sa
place dans la création quand on écrit on
écrit pour que la personne qui nous lie
on comprend alors pour que la personne
puisse nous comprendre on doit
s'adresser à cette personne là avec
simenon avec ses expressions et je me
suis permis beaucoup de choses qu'en
français je me serais pas permis une
longue créative et riche à l'image de
kinshasa un carrefour où des congolais
des quatre coins du pays se croisent au
sein d'un même foyer on passe souvent
d'une langue à l'autre sans effort une
richesse que le dramaturge michael du
banga veut mettre en avant dans ses
pièces j
à ce niveau également
chaque langue à une musicalité et cette
musicalité apportant une certaine
dimension du poésie dans la presse et
c'est à cet endroit que mes pièces sont
souvent des piges était devant comme ça
tu peux trouver plusieurs langues qui
c'est un prix en plus du français et des
quatre langues nationales lingala
swahili kikongo et chiluba les
linguistes estiment qu'il ya entre 200
et 400 langues et dialectes parlés en
rdc
notre invité à fait de la langue et de
ses traductions un objet de philosophie
en soi matière qu'il enseigne à
l'université de columbia new york il est
sénégalais né à saint-louis grandi à
ziguinchor a étudié à paris avant de
s'établir depuis plusieurs décennies aux
états unis souleymane bachir diagne est
notre invité merci d'être avec nous ce
soir merci de m'accueillir et alors
l'actualité est riche en ce moment c'est
la guerre que mène la russie en ukraine
depuis le 24 février dernier j'avais
envie de vous entendre parce qu'on a
très peu entendu finalement les
intellectuels africains sur cette
question sur les 54 pays africains 24
ont préféré ne pas approuver la
résolution onusienne condamnant
l'agression russe contre l'ukraine ou
voté contre pour vous est-ce que le
signe d'une nouvelle ère certains ont
vécu et une volonté de non alignement
rappelant à la conférence demandons de
55 quel est votre avis là-dessus vous
savez le non alignement a bon dos parce
que le non alignement c'était le refus
de s'aligner sur l'un des deux grands
blocs le bloc de l'est c'est le bloc de
l'ouest ici il s'agit qu'il ne s'agit
pas de s'indigner sur un bloc donc
invoquer le non alignement c'est
véritablement l'histoire du petit peu de
signification première de ce concept de
non alignement il est vrai il faut le
constater que les pays africains qui se
sont abstenus on joue et de la prudence
au fond ils ont manifesté une certaine
prudence diplomatique tout en faisant
savoir au fond que sur le plan des
principes il condamné
ça n'a pas été l'objet d'un vote mais
cela a été quand même clarifier dans
telle ou telle déclaration et c'était ça
qui était véritablement l'enjeu il ne
s'agissait pas encore une fois de
s'aligner sur un bloc il s'agissait de
regarder où se trouvaient les principes
et de s'aligner sur des principes le
principe premier étant en droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes il
s'avère et on le voit maintenant par la
résistance farouche qui l'oppose à
l'invasion qu'il ya un peuple ukrainien
que ce peuple ukrainienne n'entendait
pas être absorbé par l'hallucinante en
pas non plus que la russie lui dicte
ses orientations diplomatiques et sa
place dans le monde et s'est plaint
cible à son clair on laisse des
principes là sont claires et de la même
manière que ces principes sont claires
les faits montrent que
nous vivons une époque absolument
terrible oui mais alors est ce que est
ce que ça veut dire pour autant que
c'est une nouvelle ère et que finalement
on peut y lire une nouvelle géopolitique
et est ce que finalement l'afrique à
l'occasion de cette crise
vad je sais pas peut j'allais dire une
expression peut-être malheureuse mais
tirer son épingle du jeu alors en tout
cas donner à nouveau là dans la
géopolitique internationale c'est le
plan géopolitique évidemment
quelque chose d'autre à part être
maintenant c'est un point d'inflexion
cette guerre on l'a rappelé à l'envi
c'est la première fois depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale que une guerre
de cette ampleur et de cette nature se
passe sur le continent européen c'est
également la première fois depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale que des réfugiés
en si grand nombre qu'on reconnaît à
trois millions et demi aujourd'hui se
déplace sur le continent européen et par
ailleurs par ailleurs il ne faut pas
oublier que la réponse juste ici à
l'invasion ça a été les sanctions mais
les sanctions sont un couple au couteau
à double tranchant on sanctionne
évidemment la russie mais on se
sanctionnent soi même on a parlé du prix
du pétrole et de l'essence en ce moment
le monde découvre ou redécouvre pour ce
qu'il ne savait pas que l'ukraine est le
grenier à blé du monde et par conséquent
il y a des conséquences économiques on
parle même on prononce le mot de famine
ça veut dire donc non seulement les
choses ont bougé et de manière
décisif sur le plan géopolitique mais
que les conséquences qui s'annoncent
vont être pour la plupart imprévisible
et malheureusement on sait que ça va
être des conséquences qui vont être très
dures et notamment et notamment pour le
continent africain absolument pour les
crises qui se passe dans le monde
finissent toujours par être des crises
africaines c'est ça qui est terrible
c'est ça qui est terrible et alors je
voulais quand même qu'on parle de votre
livre de langue à langue publié chez
albin michel le point de départ de ce
livre c'est cette jeune poétesse amanda
à gorman qu'on a vu à l'investiture de
joe biden donc aux états unis le
président américain et vous dites que
c'est vrai que ça a suscité une
polémique sa traduction la traduction de
son ouvrage par les néerlandais
rappelez-nous rapidement le contexte et
dites nous pourquoi vous pensez que
finalement la traduction c'est un objet
de domination alors j'ai tenu à ouvrir
mon livre sur non seulement d'abord sur
cette scène cette scène magnifique a
besoin de de l'investiture de dubaï
données de kamala harris
cdn poétesse
noir qui a livré qu'il est ci dessus une
cadence absolument sublime un magnifique
poème et c'est de récitation de son
poème a finalement résumé en quelques
sortes la signification de ce moment
d'investiture qui était un moment
également de de restauration et des
victoires de la démocratie parce que la
démocratie avait tremblé sur ses bases
quelques semaines plus tôt le 6 janvier
lorsque le capital a été attaqué par des
suprémacistes des néonazis et bien
évidemment le monde est tombé sous le
charme est une manière de tomber sous le
charme d'un texte et de vouloir le
traduire c'est de vouloir l'accueillir
dans sa propre langue et on a vu un
éditeur néerlandais vouloir qu une
poétesse néerlandaise soit la
traductrice de ce poème est là
la controverse a éclaté
oui parce qu elle était blanche la tête
de lang blanche et on a dit qu'elle
pouvait pas se rendre on a estimé que
la poétesse noir une poétesse noir ne
pouvait être traduites que par une femme
noire qui partagé par conséquent la même
expérience d'avoir
ces identités visible
il faut dire une chose évidemment il
faut se battre pour que ce qui les lie
minorités visibles
puissent avoir leur place également dans
un certain nombre de secteurs en
particulier le secteur de la traduction
de secteurs de l'édition et donc ça
c'est un principe sur lequel il faut il
faut être absolument intransigeant et se
battre mais mes demandes et que une
femme noire soit par excellence la
taille du tice d'une autre femme noire
c'est se tromper c'est faire en
contresens sur la notion traduction oui
et c'est ceux là le point de départ de
mon livre ici ce qui a nourri au fond ma
réflexion sur la signification de la
traduction alors je vous conseille
vivement d'aller lire le livre pour en
savoir plus justement c'est absolument
magnifique et vous concluez évidemment
sur le fait que la traduction ça ouvre
aussi les champs des possibles ça
rapproche les peuples c'est un humanisme
merci beaucoup souleymane bachir diagne
c'est la fin de ce journal merci d'être
avec nous reste à nouveau son actualité
continue sur france 24
[Musique]